[Music]
[Applause]
for you
[Music]
ah
ydd
[Music]
i
[Applause]
for me
[Music]
no  no no
day by day
[Applause]
[Music]
but
I'm leaving
the cave
[Music]
[Applause]
to day
[Music]
and life
or not
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[  Music]
d [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
my life
[Music]
[Applause]
and she
no no no
[Music]
[Applause]
iy
ah
[Music]
look at this
[Applause]
until they give us bills
comrades
[Music]
now
and now
i
[Music] it
's undeniable
the same channel
no no
[Applause  ]
however
[Music]
efe
d
[Music]
why not
i
being my son
in January
at this time
m
arrived
had the logger
son
about  impressions
of  in the same way
because they have turned
free
we don't want it in the same way
because I could peak at the
public officials who had a lot of
participation in the jones case it was
for the world
in two letters they have done nothing they have not
been judged
valencia since seizing
a model  the public official will tell the
truth,
for example about the low ones,
but
the public officials sold him
to these culprits
in the same way
we are not going to leave him in impunity
we are not going to leave him in the same way with a
68 on his coat
and protesting shouting because they
show us  43 close-up cameras
ah
in our mexico
cries out for having a different idea than
this every teacher
this state has for our people
and
where
[Music] they
also gave
is a lie
from politics
a state as when they saw us they thought they
don't repress
in the same way
it doesn't matter
with some expressions of the norm
with groups of independent experts
research
[Music]
and are following up l  is we ask
you to continue
[Music]
[Applause]
and what we did
[Music]
no
good
the skin
[Music]
and
no no no
[Applause]
[Music]
no
no no no
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music  ]
[Music]
and
the determination
i
this year
[Music]
and
na
[Music]
strains of the born and the
unborn that we were not born to be chosen
we were born to put whose abode only
turns 6 years old 6 am on that night
that's why our comrades were
kidnapped
[Music]
of life
we live it we believe
[Music]
I
[Applause]
[Music]
but not
[Applause]
[Music]
teacher
[Applause]
something
[Music]
no no no
no
e
[Music]
okay
no no no
ah
being
[Music]
and
a lima
ah
but not
[Music]
i
good
and
[Music]
[Applause]
the day
[Music]
no no no
but not
[Applause]
[Music]
and
bi  in
[Music]
but
now
ah
[Music]
I don't know
i
[Music]
while working
and a lot
several sections
i
he
[Music]
yes no
[Applause]
[Music]
look
[Applause]
[Music]
but on a Sunday
yes
[Music]
is let's say
[Music  ]
[Music]
[Applause]
good
[Music]
[Applause]
but not
very good
[Music]
[Applause]
no  no no
[Music]
look
[Applause]
or not
[Applause
] me
or not
[Music]
yes yes
why
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
and
[Music
]  he